there's no
guarantee that they can in in all cases
get
all the individuals sometimes they may
um people involved
perhaps at the lower level but maybe
people at a higher level
have covered their tracks well enough
that they don't get prosecuted
successfully or even prosecuted at all
i'll give you one example
where they managed to successfully
prosecute
a number of different people in the
coven so this is in in a way it's it's
one of the
more positive recent examples of what
the police can do
successfully in an sra case
when they actually tried to do their job
i actually went to a talk by one of the
police detectives on this
case and she made it clear that it
wasn't easy
but because they persisted and they had
the will to pursue the investigation
they achieved this successful
prosecution of a number of
satanist abusers and in my view that is
an example of what other police forces
can achieve
across the uk if they actually have the
will
to investigate and pursue these
investigations
the biggest problem is not lack of
resources the biggest problem
is lack of will you see so
um i'll read out this successfully
prosecuted case and he'll give you
an example of what can be achieved when
the police are willing to do their job
on march 11 2011 colin batley
the leader of the satanist coven was
convicted at swansea crown court debts
in wales
of more than 20 sexual offenses against
children including 11 rapes
he and other satanists had ritually
abused children in tidwelly wales
where their coven was based the children
some as young as
11 were subjected to and i quote
organized and systematic abuse by batley
his wife and two women coven members
so it wasn't just bradley who got
prosecuted his wife and two
women covered members
jacqueline marling age 42 was jailed for
12 years for aiding and abetting rape
causing prostitution indecency with a
child
and inciting a child to engage in sexual
activity
badly's wife elaine age 47 was jailed
for eight years on three charges of
indecency
with a child and sexual activity with a
child
shelley miller aged 35 was jailed for
five years
for indecency with a child and inciting
a child to engage
in sex a fifth defendant vincent baden
aged
17 admitted assaulting an underage girl
so this was a pretty good
prosecution and successful prosecution
against a satanist group that managed to
get
custodial sentences for
a lot of the members of the group and
is a positive example of what can be
achieved
if the police want to achieve it
it all comes back to will willingness to
really
go for the for the investigation pursue
it thoroughly
have you ever been to one of these or
ever seen witnessed one of these rituals
i've witnessed a ritual
satanist leaving a ritual
having just finished where was it
when when was it what did it look like
it was
well it was indoors so i couldn't get in
but i saw them leaving the ritual
because i didn't get that till
quite late at night because i'd been at
other locations
checking out other locations before i
got there
and that was the one with the satanist
meeting
in the building and they were leaving
and driving off but i saw
in a car at the back of the car
there was a man about age 40 years old
and in the front
was a boy um and of course you got to
ask yourself it was about
4am what is the boy at 4 am doing in the
front of a car not in bed
uh with this man dressed as well he was
dressed like dracula
at the back dracula yeah and
that in itself causes a lot of questions
why is this going up at
4am and why is he sitting in a car with
a man
dressed as dracula in the back okay it
was halloween but
and that was probably the cover story oh
you know just a halloween time but
keeping a boy up to that this one this
was on halloween
um yeah 31st october which is their
biggest date on the
satanist calendar
uh if there's one day they will come out
and do a ritual somewhere
it will be 31st october to them it's the
most important date of the year
why is that um also because of the
belief that that is when the the
barriers between
this world and the spirit world
become most easily crossed
and they have of course a desire
to get in contact with demons to raise
demons
to communicate with demons so
this would be a pretty good time for
them to try and raise the demons and
communicate demons because of the
the lowering of the barriers between the
physical and the spirit world
in their beliefs
they
they would usually meet on this date
so that makes it a bit easier to do
surveillance because
other dates sometimes they'll meet on
the actual date sometimes they'll meet
a bit earlier on another date uh or
after that date
birthday as you mentioned yeah uh
birthdays normally
i think they would meet on the birthday
itself
um another occasion when i knew they
were meeting
unfortunately these tended to be indoors
rather than others outdoors would be so
much easier to see them
what they're doing was in a house
that i know is protected by the police
because i know someone who tried to
expose that house is being used for sra
and the police not only refused to do
anything but actually
threaten this person for
nosing about in that area and and
warned her that she might get
hurt from nosing around where it wasn't
they claimed her business of course it
was a business because
her own child had revealed being abused
in that house
and the police were protecting it it's a
location
that has been used for sra for many
years
and i was there on the outside
legally i couldn't just go in
uh and i knew that the satanists were in
there because i could see their
their um their vehicles on the outside
and uh i heard a scream
in from inside a young girl at about
3 a.m it was a short screen
if it had been a long scream and helped
me
calling out for help then i would
probably have had more legal
justification
to force my way in
but because it was a short screen and it
didn't repeat itself
for the rest of the night it was hard
have a legal grounds to to force my way
in because if i force my way in
and there isn't reasonable grounds to
justify that
then uh then the tables could be turned
and i could be accused of breaking the
law so
this is the difficulties one has when
you're talking about
indoors meetings they do meet outdoors a
lot
the the tricky thing is to get them
outdoors when they are meeting uh
because they have a variety most covens
will have a variety
of outdoor and indoor locations for
security reasons
and they move from one place to another
and i noticed that if they meet at one
location
on halloween the next halloween they'll
make sure they meet at another location
so they don't become predictable
okay can you walk
through what happened oh sorry go ahead
yeah sorry but but if
um if
one was to come across then doing a
ritual
uh i think it's important to
to at the very least try and get the
police there
uh i would i would suggest to audience
members if they ever come across
sometimes
i know in the uk at least sometimes
people have stumbled on accidentally
to satanist rituals in the middle of the
night
when they were in the woods for example
and i would say try and get the police
there
as soon as possible if you see that
harm is being done to children even the
presence of children there is enough to
to warrant police interests because what
on earth are children doing in the
middle of the night
in this location they should all be in
bed
you know and it's very suspicious
and this this
is what
one should do on those rare occasions
that one stumbles across these things
and i've seen some accounts of people
stumbling on such things
when they least expect it sometimes and
they come across this
satan is gathering uh
in uh usually it's a countryside area or
woods
i